It was a scene Americans never expected to see, not in their country.
The images ricocheted around the nation on TV...
...and private chat groups on social media.
It started with a peaceful gathering Wednesday...
...headlined by President Donald Trump...
...to protest the results of the US presidential election.
Just a mile away, a joint session of Congress...
...began the process of certifying those results.
We will never give up.
We will never concede.
It doesn't happen.
You don't concede when there's theft involved.
Trump suggested protesters walk to the Capitol.
As the crowd approached the building,...
...they pushed up against police lines and their demeanor changed.
They forced their way into the building and lawmakers fled.
Seeing protesters in US cities is not unusual.
Over the summer, unrest, at times, turn to violence and destruction,...
...but what happened Wednesday in Washington DC was different.
As night fell, and Washington fell under a curfew,...
...a stunned nation grappled to understand...
...what led to this unprecedented moment.
The Capitol Building, the scene of so many historical moments,...
...but nothing like this.
Michelle Quinn, VOA News.